yes thank you hi
um I think it's a good talk before lunch
I'm gonna be talking about short
proteins
okay uh unplannable polymers and their
cryptographic application this is Joint
work with a bunch of people
uh here is a legend uh so radar
who was here before isn't here yeah
um myself and Iran Tomer are
cryptographers who hopefully you all
know and love
computational biologists and uh Johnny
gillshoni and Anna right Bird Berman
are a biochemists wet lab
people they're the ones we managed to
find who are brave enough to talk to us
good so
um let me start with the preview uh
please no questions during the preview
it's short it's meant to bring questions
but I don't want to answer them as soon
as the preview is over you can ask
questions I encourage it okay so this is
like a big summary of what I'll talk
about so we propose a new biological
approach which includes both a
biological process for the honest
parties and a biological hardness
assumptions against this or dishonest
parties I want to note that the good
guys the honest Party part is also
really really hard
uh it's not just oh let's talk about the
hardness uh and then we use this new uh
proposed approach to construct something
we called consumable tokens uh which is
a very extremely very weak version of
bounded query memory something like uh
one-time memory of gkr called faster Rod
Bloom and kalai
who happened to be here yeah
um
and then so and then we use that to
construct some cryptographic
applications which are digital locker
and some version of k-time program so
I'll explain what all of this means
um so one if you start from the
consumable token you can just think of
it as a very simple primitive you can
forget all the biology what can you do
with this very weak primitive
okay but actually modeling it and coming
up with the Primitive a lot of the work
went into defining the right primitive
that we could justify in biology and
then some kind of formal way to say this
is justified by biology so there was a
lot of work there
um
okay good so I'm gonna
oh let me say what the critics are
saying
um I'm not gonna read it all can you see
it well you can read for yourself
um
um can anybody guess who the next quote
will be by
Ron correct
the rankinabi quote is made up but
everything else is in fact true there's
a tiny uh asterisk was in fact said but
not about our work just in general
yesterday on the panel
yes I could be a journalist right
but anyway I feel it's appropriate so I
quoted it
okay good so that's the preview so I'm
Gonna Keep It Low on the technical
details both because of time and because
they're it's not clear to me what to
focus on the biology or the crypto the
biology I don't know about but the
crypto is like more standard and but
although there's some non-standard
things in the crypto that come because
of the biology so I'll kind of try to do
everything but at a high informal level
if you ask a lot of questions and I
don't get to something that's fine too
um you value you'll tell me about that
this is the same sliders before you'll
tell me about time how much time is left
Etc I forgot to know this okay
all right so let me start with very uh
informal high level assume you had a
bounded query memory device
okay what does it mean there's a memory
device it has some message m in it uh
and you want to be able to retrieve it
but then as soon as you retrieve it it's
self-distracts okay so it's a one time
you can read it and that's it then it's
self-destruct obviously it has to be
uncleanable otherwise it makes no sense
you clone many times and then you can
read it many times okay that's a bounded
query memory device some it's something
useful that we would like to have uh by
the way a lot of the slides are made by
Radha almashakbe just to give credit
including whatever you're trying to read
there this message was self-distract in
five seconds okay
um you can also think of a slightly more
general idea of a memory that doesn't
have just m but has like four messages
m-y-x-a and you're allow to retrieve any
two of them but as soon as you retrieve
the two of them they self-distract okay
this is a primitive that's really useful
uh I'll call it bounded query memory
device and it was shown to imply bounded
execution software like a one-time
program like you can have a program
arbitrary generic program that anybody
could use a certain number of times and
no more for a limited time okay so this
was given by goldmaster Kalyan Rod Bloom
um I'll say a tiny bit more about it in
a second in the classical model it was
also done in the quantum model by
broadband glutowsky and Stabila
um
good but how how did they get I want I
don't want to focus on this
transformation but more on the how the
bounded query memory device where did it
come from how do we build it okay so uh
in the gkr it was just a hypothetical
device it was a very small conceptually
thing it's just a one out of two or
three there are two messages you take
one and then it's self-distract
okay and using that they did arbitrary
program
limited time execution but where do you
get it from uh so the only thing to do
it from uh or I guess there are many
related works that I could talk about
and I won't but
the point is oh we could just use
Hardware assumption temperature proofing
it but I want to point out that as far
as we know there is no
the fact that it's such a simple small
nice thing
is not so helpful in Hardware there's no
like in order to have tamper proof you
just need to assume you just time to
approve the whole process you might as
well just temper proof everything it's
an assumption that's not we don't know
how to achieve it from smaller
components and also you know there's
like Channel attacks as this assumption
really makes sense I also want to say I
don't think I didn't think about this
deeply but it seems to me this
assumption is also
the hardware assumption is not a win-win
situation if it turns out to be false
then it's only a lose
but anyway this Hardware assumption is
something sort of competing with ours
but we suggest a new way to do it from
biology
okay
um so this is uh what we want to do so
our points are unclownable and
self-destructive memory devices uh okay
I sort of said that there's formal
modeling and Analysis and what we get is
really really weak and so we need to do
amplification and for amplification we
use both standard crypto staff and also
less standard because there are things
that are annoying that need to be dealt
with okay and then we show some
cryptographic applications hopefully
there'll be more
thank you
um okay so let me give a taste of what
how we build it from biology so let me
start with something that we do not do
this is not us but just to motivate
DNA is something that's really robust
and amazing you can find DNA from a
thousand years ago dried up and easily
make a million copies of it and sequence
it and reading it it's great
not so easy
um you've got a Nobel Prize for that
okay but their work can now be used
right
[Music]
this was a direct quote from a biologist
what I said about the thousand years ago
it dried up a million I did yeah
but you know anyway not the one who got
a noble Christ we don't lie in
introductions
anyway this is not what we do
that okay so what is the DNA is like
what's the and and then there's uh
recently or maybe it's not so recently
anymore the word which suggests to use
DNA for storage so you have a message
you encode it uh into a DNA this is not
hard it's robust it saves it keeps for a
long time it's great
um however it's the opposite of what we
want for we wanted something to be
uncloneable okay not so robust in fact
we want the opposite so we wanted to do
something biological but the main thing
that people do DNA based is not
appropriate for us in fact it's the
opposite
um okay uh however there's a different
type of polymer uh which is proteins in
fact
okay proteins is what we do proteins I'm
told proteins refers usually to a very
long sequence and for us it's a short
sequence it's called a peptide but in
any case uh this is a different type of
a way to encode a message into a
sequence of things in this case it would
be amino acids and it's also not so hard
maybe a little harder than DNA but it's
not so hard apparently to build you know
any short sequence you give me uh I
could build going through a DNA I could
build a peptide protein that encodes it
in a sequence
okay
but
but it is not clonable uh and it's not
easy we want to say it's not easy to
read it back okay so why do we want to
say that
um so this is the central dogma
molecular biology the this is a copy of
what uh Crick
wrote in 1957 this is something
biologists no it's famous central dogma
this is his words the central dogma is
his words but the lines are ours uh once
information has got into a protein it
can't get out again information here
means the sequence of the amino acid
residues or other sequence related to it
that is we may be able to have you see
DNA to RNA RNA to protein DNA to protein
DNA to itself
just like um cloning RNA to itself RNA
to DNA we can do all of that but we can
never go from protein to DNA or protein
to itself
your goal is to try to do a one-time
program using biology right yes so you
want to encode the information and
television Hardware using biology yes
it's not the main thing there is the
self-destruction right that you can read
and self-destruct it's not like see like
what you're saying here oh it's not
self-destructive by definition because
it can't read
I don't understand your question it it
it's it's self-destructed not just
because you can't read I'll say a little
more about it but I didn't but I don't
understand your question tell me again
okay so what you're trying to do right I
mean what you're saying is oh it's great
I'm going to use my encode my thing in a
protein yes okay
but I need to then read yes oh so you're
saying how do I read it you just say you
can
good yes I agree okay this is just the
starting point this is why we needed to
work hard to make it happen yeah but I
now I understand your question yes good
I'll answer it was quick talking about
like what humans can do or what the body
does
good good this is related to you want to
say something related to your else
question you a guy said for proteins
there I can look at it and read it you
can't really you cannot read it I'll say
a little more about it like in one more
slide ask me again both of you
um
I just wanted to so I mean what he talks
about this both like the human body and
Technology
okay that's what we thought and that you
can take a protein so if you give me a
DNA I can build a protein out of it
given a protein I cannot build a DNA out
of it and I cannot make another protein
out of it but reading in a microscope
and your else question I'll answer in a
second I just want to say this picture
that he drew looks exactly like the
pictures I draw in my crypto classes
right it's really the same that's
basically what he's saying so we want to
take advantage of it and do some crypto
out of it so good now let's talk about
the reading what is reading which
microscope so the microscope you
mentioned is called a mass spec Mass
spectrometry device
um so in fact it is possible to read
proteins but extremely extreme what does
read reader's sequence what what is the
sequence that composes them it's a
extremely extremely hard you'll need a
lot of material and it needs to be very
very pure
okay this is what our biologists caught
us tell us we kept asking them and
pushing them about well but maybe it's
easy maybe the adversary could do it
maybe the adversary has a stronger Mass
Effect just want to say all our culture
of discussing with them with the
biologist
they it's obvious to them that an
adversary cannot do it but they're a
little worried about our scheme that the
good guys might not be able to do it
either because reading is really really
hard
okay so this is the point but we the the
like we hope it looks really good oh you
say you need a lot of materials
you mean the proteins or the chemicals
the proteins the proteins
no not many copies the the okay so you
need a vial with some stuff in it the
stuff needs to be pure and you put it in
the machine this machine and the Machine
reads it by breaking it up into little
pieces and I don't know what measuring I
don't know what it does
and tries to read it and something comes
out at that time this was destroyed so
you need the high Purity in order for
the reading to be successful and you
need a lot in the sense that when you
like it destroys the material
please
I am not
or anyone else actually who knows
biology please I want to be offended the
important there is that they need a a
microscope a microscopic amount of
material in order to read from it
and uh and then it's destroyed oh it's
funny macroscopic so yeah that's
microscopic but microscope you need a
lot and it needs to be pure
yes yes
and it needs to be without other junk
inside
when you do the reading you're shooting
it with a laser and like that's yeah it
died so so the self-destruct is really
really completely it's like burning it
yeah
[Music]
yes there are some proteins that are
easily distinguishable from each other I
agree but it's like like wait there are
things you can do like measure the
weight or the mass or things like that
yeah
you have different proteins what for
different functions we got different
proteins here they would be all the same
it's good that's good so for us they're
short they're like about 20 amino acids
it's not a full protein it's a peptide
it's short so it's harder but indeed the
scheme uses like we don't we don't have
all possible amino acids but only ones
that are look similar and cannot be
distinguished things like that there's a
lot of chemical work going into it
[Music]
um
good but anyway so what do we do with
this we want to build a consumable
memory token so here is an idea of how
to do it
um so first you uh synthesize
uh peptide
from a message you encoded there's amino
acid and you make a protein out of it
then you attach a header to it this so
okay but by the way the biological stuff
which I don't know much about some of
the stuff we're doing is standard bio
staff that all the biologists say it's
standard and easy and some of it is
novel biological techniques okay I was
told that figuring out how to attach the
header in a good way so that it's easy
to cleave is a new novel contribution of
our work
great
I don't know anyway uh right whereas
synthesizing M into a protein is not as
easy apparently anyway uh this we did
this we being the authors
actually yeah I'll show I'll show a
picture of us doing it
uh good uh so you synthesize that you
attach a header okay so a header is also
a sequence a shorter sequence of amino
acids and the header is such that there
is an antibody that corresponds to it
right which you can send to someone you
can send even digitally the you know
sequence that makes the header that
tells you what the sequence for the
antibody is that can attach to it why do
we want to do that oh yeah this is a
picture of it this is Anna she's a
co-author and this is the vial so this
is really actually this
it's not a stock picture it's actually
Anna
okay see so we're doing it here
um and then we mix with decoy protein
because of the Purity aspect you are
right that you need to be careful that
the decoy proteins are harder to
distinguish okay I will say more about
it sometimes even if you can distinguish
and you know the key
still our schemes will be secure I'll
say what I mean in a minute but anyway
in the most basic consumable talk and
this is what we do we mix with decoy
proteins and then the point is that
um one second then the point is this so
so this is how do you prepare this
consumable token how do you use it how
do you consume it so the good guy first
purifies by The Good the antibody is the
secret key okay the good guy can purify
by pulling down the correct protein and
now it's pure enough or many of them the
macroscopic amount of them then it's
pure enough that you can run it through
the mass spec and sequence it and then
it's gone the adversary on the other
hand could maybe try but every try every
pull down even with the wrong key
destroys
uh the solution running it destroy the
solution so if you don't know the key
you can't do it well this is very
simplistic
yeah the antibody pulls down uh this
particular header the antibodies related
to the header so this is before going to
the Mass Effect there's a pull down
procedure I don't know what it looks
like chemically
nothing it just takes only the good guy
with the appropriate header
yeah it gets all the guys with the right
header that matches to it and pulls all
of them down and now you have a pure
solution and then you can put the pure
solution in the Mass Effect yeah I mean
I'm trying to understand what your token
does is it like uh there's two messages
oh good I'll say I'll give a
cryptographic definition in a minute
also not formally I'll give it in a
minute and you will see what it does one
time program exactly in the center no
it's not that one it's something else
right I'll say what it does and then
I'll say how we use it
we use this in order to achieve a
one-time program but that's not it's not
fair to say in the end we use it class
IO plus one-way function and we cannot
program
you need like a bike or like a marker
like a kind of a bounce out of its
protein you can always like break them
into two right like it's good then I can
like simply take copies like if good
good so the adversary can always like
just take half of the yeah like just
take habits take half of this to the
machine excellent this is a good attack
so ideally we would want to give the
minimal possible that you can read this
is not a good notion because maybe the
adversary has a better stronger aspect
than you
um and you can do that and so what we
will do you will see in a minute is you
will we will assume the adversary has
more power but still
you know the adversary can read some
more than you let me let me get to it in
one second it is a good attack I mean I
give you little so you cannot divide it
too many times but you're right that we
can't be so exact because whom the
adversary may be richer with a newer
better Mass Spec newer technology or
something like that so we will account
for this in our motto
um
good here this is the answer both to you
and to you it's a fine-grained
biological people
find great biological cryptography it's
true but then we use it to build real
cryptography that's not fine-grained
which is part of the reason it's hard
sorry I don't mean to complain uh
okay so here is
um
here is here is a now you can forget the
biology here is something
you can I could Define this is not a
formal definition but we do have a
formal definition in the paper
um this is a consumable token well I
guess
let me think maybe I should just show
this one is better uh
yeah let me just do this one okay good
here is our model this is a consumable
token a neutral account for your attack
and it will account for your question so
it's a 1n v consumable token this is a
definition you could just Define and now
forget the biology and do whatever you
want with it and see what you can get so
there's a vial it has v uh pairs of key
message pairs V key message pairs okay
um now it's a vial or ideal
functionality
when you wanna if you submit a k
Prime that equals one of the rows you
get back Mi
um where if you submit a wrong Decay you
get nothing okay that's sort of the
functionality the good guy is allowed
one query and then it's gone it's not we
assume the good guy can never do more
because we gave them too little it's
self-distract with the adversary we
allow end queries exactly in order to
account for these attacks
of the adversary can divide it more
sophisticated okay so we allow it's uh
so for the security the adversary is
assumed to have n n is some small or
some constant uh in fact everything
there is small and constant it's not big
huge cryptographic length so we assume
this token can be effectively read by
the good guy once and can be effectively
read by the bad guy no more than n times
okay and notice here even if you do know
the keys all the keys there's no secret
even if you know all the keys you still
cannot read more than end things just
because of the self-destruct probability
I'm going to learn some Global partial
information like authority of everything
yeah good so
there isn't I guess so you I could
defining an idea
exactly so there are two ways to
understand your question one is how what
my definition said my definition says
there is no way that's the only thing
you can do and that's it it's an ideal
functionality for the biology we try to
work hard to prove it
it's um under some model
uh yeah good you don't get partial
information either I mean really in
reality in biology you could submit some
key that is very similar and maybe it
pulls down and also there's a
soundness error that is non-negligible
like you might somehow retrieve
something even without a key so we took
all these things into account
um good so this is the biological
primitive consumable token
um
even if you could get some Global
linkage
not necessarily mean that your
construction is broken or just didn't
look into it so it's probably more of us
[Music]
yeah I'm trying to think maybe we did
look into it we didn't right
but but you're right it's not uh if you
maybe you could uh have an ideal
functionality where the sun is without
the number of bits here
yeah but the thing is we were yeah
I think what we were talking about
jumping ahead but the modeling we're
trying to do we try to say let's to kind
of look amplification kind of quote
unquote but we have some this single
print single print which talks about six
numbers
you know leakage and detections
yeah but but the thing is we have much
less freedom because we want to be
true to the biological thing so we can't
just Define it in any way but maybe it's
interesting and yeah defining generals
Lambda leakage yeah yeah
some sort of answer for how long you can
store these tokens just concreting I do
not do you know
and they thought that it should be able
to keep for for a while
at the right temperature
yes good I can
um
good so let me think how many things I
well I to tell you some numbers about
the length which is not what you're
asking but the lengths are about like
total like 30 amino acids
each the key is like 10 amino acid amino
acid is like five bits
uh that's the length it's not an answer
for how many do we store
I don't know uh what makes sense maybe
any number
[Music]
should make sense
I don't know if there is a real
limitation on V what there is a real
limitation of the one and N shouldn't be
the same otherwise it kind of doesn't
make sense and should be bigger because
yes
they're like 50 bits or something like
that the honest party also I said yes
yeah but it's not a guess you can give
it to them actually by the way the
I mean in my final application I want
normal crypto with one keys I also you
use the word guess I also want to say
even if you know all the keys the
self-destruct property home it's not a
matter of secrecy it's that
in order to get from this weird dirty
biological staff a message M you need to
destroy some of it and so you can do it
at most end times
um good
uh
okay we have an ideal functionality let
me think about it oh okay this is a
whole thing that I don't want to discuss
but how I said how do we justify this
ideal functionality fits the biology we
actually have an even lower level
abstraction we call the vector model the
vector is amounts a quantities of each
type of
uh each kind of protein and and then we
model how you do I don't know pull down
or like different biological operations
and then we show that with this more
close we have a intermediate model
that's closer to biology but still mass
and using that we prove that this is
realized but this I don't want to talk
about
anyway at this point we have an ideal
functionality fct consumable token one
NV uh and the question is what we can do
with it and this is why I said it's
really really oh and this ideal
functionality has unlike what you used
to none uh negligible soundness error
that's important okay
it's written in full formality in our
paper
um okay
good and now we wanna
um like Quran was saying before we wanna
amplify it okay to something better
okay this is highlights of the model so
far not of the future results the
non-negligible soundness is the main
thing I wanted to say
and then I think I said everything else
before
yeah the only meaning for everything
else I said in answers to questions uh
before
okay so and this also I said the hard
part is amplifying weak constant size
properties to like standard
cryptographic functionalities
uh good so let me say Yvonne how much
time do I have
yeah I can finish in any amount of time
I can finish now I can finish in five
hours whatever is so seriously it's easy
to talk little or a lot
uh good so let me say something about
the applications
um I already said about the one-time
program I hinted about it but that will
be my second application let me start
with the first application
uh which uh is digital Locker so you
wanna you encode a message M with a
password and the point is the password
has low entropy like a you like a
password that's easy to run an
exhaustive search on uh but I want the
lock to after a few you know it's like
when you've entered the wrong thing a
few numbers some number of times a small
number of times it's self-distract and
it locks forever so you can never get
back again right because the password
has low entropy so you have to do it so
this is what we want to implement
uh and this seems like this is a seems
like obviously of course we can
implement it using our consumable token
assumption uh oh this is a definition of
the same thing sorry more formal
definition this description informal
description is the same as Point
function obfuscation right but with
bounded query so
think of the following functionality
uh
I have the input is p Prime if P Prime
equals P then I give you m back p is the
password and otherwise I give you
nothing back I'm just writing the same
functionality as before and more
mathematical terms and pointing out that
it's the same as Point function
obfuscation
with the point being you cannot call it
more than a small number of times it's
bounded query okay so there's a password
and you query it and you get the message
inside if the password is correct and
otherwise you get nothing and after a
small number of application itself
distracts
okay
um
good so in the honest party can uh it
sounds very similar to what we already
have it sounds like trivial to achieve
it right because the honest party will
just run it with the correct p and the
adversary can try up to end passwords
but it doesn't know P so
it's exactly what we wanted
um
right so just like a spoiler the answer
will be no not so immediate but at the
end we will achieve it
um good so the first attempt that seems
immediate is you just encode you know
you just put one message in there and if
you give the case the password or you
know you derive a key from the password
if you put the K you get M and if you
put a wrong K you don't get M and that's
exactly it the problem with just
applying it as is without any thought is
exactly the
um non-negligible soundness
well if it had negligible soundness it
would be medium
um by the way there is also an issue of
non-negligible completeness but I'm
ignoring it because this result in
biological Ways by sending many vials so
I'm ignoring it whereas the soundness we
address in a cryptographic way so I'm
talking about it anyway just using as is
not good because there's not negligible
soundness
uh error so not error but um like the
adversary might read it even without the
correct key and so what we want to do
um so the next idea is to just use
standard amplification technique of
secret sharing so instead of encoding
one thing I give you and you
you different vials and you need to
figure all of them out in order to uh
get the message because it's a secret
sharing and and out events you out of
you secretary
okay and that's that does boost the
error the gamma it boosts it to
negligible because gamma goes to gamma
to the U you know if you just happen to
be lucky with probability gamma you will
be lucky on all of them in negligible
probability but that's the standard
stuff we know and that's great
but the problem is it's still there's a
different Source you don't have to read
carefully I'll tell you where the
sources there's a different source of
magnitude probability now the issue is
if you were lucky in the first one just
by chance gamma probability
non-negotiable from this you since the
password was
um low entropy you can on the side try
all possible passwords and see what's
which password mapped to K1 and then
figure out all the other K2 and succeed
so because the password had low
uh
low entropy even one success actually
giving you many vowels boosts your
probability of success because anyone's
success will allow you to offline attack
a dictionary attack and figure out and
then read the rest
and so what would like after this it's
the same in because it's the same K
because it's the same not KP so the K's
are different but they all derived from
the same password
yeah and the whole point was that it's a
low entropy password
yeah
um good so after you know all of these
problems you know finding these
somehow we looked for applications that
seemed obvious and then they were not
obvious but once you know this problem
solving it is actually not so hard so
what we do I don't want to go into the
details especially since I promise you
about I can finish at any time we do do
Secret sharing but we make sure that you
in even if you lack in one of them you
need to know you need to be like in all
previous ones in order to read it like
we hide we have high entropy secret
encoded the chains into the next vials
it doesn't matter if you don't see it
now this it's not hard uh but it's
interesting to figure out that this was
an issue
okay so anyway we succeed to do BPO
bounded query Point function obfuscation
that was one uh
application
okay and it works these numbers are not
exact but pretty good
so this is negligible error probability
in addition to just n trials
over the password space which is small
so now I want to talk a little bit about
the
apples I'll tell you what this means
when in time programs so that's the next
application that we want to achieve and
that's the one I hinted about from the
beginning so
just uh
good let me say what one and time
programs are first of all one time
program what's a one-time program it's a
program that you can run once and then
it dies and you can never run again okay
in my terminology this would be called
one comma one time program just so you
know but I have one comma n time program
why because I need to distinguish
between the good guy and the adversary
so it's a program that the good guy can
run once and then I cannot assume it can
run it anymore just once in a dime but
the adversary can run at 10 times and
then it dies okay so I have a gap so I
don't exactly achieve the one-time
program or the k-time program I achieve
it with the gap uh from my consumable
tokens
right so uh this is why I said we
achieve a version of so we don't achieve
k-time programs but we achieved k
plus 7 times program so the adversary
can run it more times than uh just
because we assume uh the underlying
consumable token has this property okay
so this is what the one end time program
is okay
here
I do have a mathematical definition of
the security effect
good I do
but not here I uh let me see if I have I
don't know if I have uh not here I have
in the paper the paper is on ePrint uh
and I can talk about it the mathematical
definition is
you know it's an idealized functionality
everything is in the UC model so uh the
ideal functionality can I mean I can
tell you more details about it
afterwards this is sort of like a ramp
setting it's like there's a there's a
idea of functionality you can ask it to
generate a program it generates it then
if uh if the adversary asks to run it
there's a count there and after you run
it and times an arbitrary inputs
desire it's distract I mean it will
never answer again
yeah is there a barrier to open one-time
programs
[Music]
I my intuitive answer is yes
I asked this of my co-hosters and
they're all like yes of course you can't
because the adversary can maybe has a
stronger machine
and I asked well but do we have like a
real impossibility result so I don't
want to say confidently no but I don't
know how to do it
uh if you want to allow the adversary
more
if you're a consumable token is your
primitive that has a gap between the one
and the N I don't know how to achieve KK
time programs I don't know it's maybe
it's possible
I think I don't want to misrepresent my
concerts but I think they're more
confident than me that it's impossible
okay
um
good Yuval is has it been 10 minutes or
no
getting better getting there okay so let
me just say
um there's one idea let me say it's as
follows like before there's one idea
that's kind of oh oh I forgot to say
also importantly when we talked about
assumptions before in the panel one
thing I really agreed with is we need to
specify our assumption that you say oh
now we do it so in addition to the
biological assumption that I talk so
much here we also use one-way function
and IO uh to achieve it
from consumable tokens
um good so one the the main idea is this
and then there are complications because
things are short and so we do some error
correcting cone and blah blah blah and
we make it happen that's the big point
so let me say the simple idea before
adding all the complicated not so
complicated actually like error
correcting codes and things like that
the idea is this
um I have a program if arbitrary program
I want to be able to run it one time for
the good guy and times with a bad guy at
most end times so for each input in the
input domain I have a secret message
stored in the token
and then I obfuscate a program
that that's the following you know given
the secret message M that corresponds to
X if M corresponds to X I obviously
obfuscate the following program I give
you X and I give you m if M and X fit
according to the secret mapping then I
output the correct output f of x
otherwise I output nothing the idea is
in order to be able to run F1 X I have
to use the token to get the secret
message and and then I can use the
obfuscated program and get what I wanted
but now I destroyed my token and I
cannot run it again that's the main idea
it doesn't really work because the token
has only short messages only a small num
n number of messages I want General
programs on you know zero one to the N I
want many possible inputs there are
issues
but those issues can be solved just in
order to uh if we'd load so this sort of
works maybe even this not quite work but
it sort of work if F had very small
domain if F has large domain it doesn't
work but we make it work
so we have an error correcting code but
then we also need to account for the
fact that when you have many vials with
many things you don't want that gives
more chances to the adversary to get
this non-negligible Advantage so you
want to set up the code parameter so
that it doesn't help
but anyway we succeed to do that
so
um yeah that's
the end of my talk I think it's exactly
according to the time eval gave me right
yeah let me say something about future
work yeah even with the current work the
biology let me just say something about
what we did already biology biologically
uh
we have an implementation of the token
we don't of you know of the token and
this was really complicated for the good
guys I'm talking about the good guys it
was really complicated to do it
but we did it we haven't yet read it in
the mass spec and they think it's
possible but there are funding issues
and there was a big delay due to they
were working on covered vaccines
seriously but there are challenges but
their challenges not just funding also
intellectual challenges to do it but
uh I think at this point I'll let you
say in a minute I think at this point we
were planning anyway to write a biology
paper with everything they did even
without the missing party they didn't do
they thought it's interesting enough for
a biology paper
that's in biology and in cryptography
there's a lot more many more
applications you can think of talk about
it Etc I'll take questions but run yeah
all those labs all those techniques that
we're doing actually where all harnessed
to do covered vaccines it's the same
technique suppression
if I'm speaking let me know I'll just
say something later he said you know it
really annoyed us at least you know that
you know do this one time programs very
nicely with just your one-way functions
and one's a memory and now we can
exactly mess up the memory and the only
thing we can do is
you can do something in the middle and
we thought about it quite a bit and we
have no way
but we don't have a barrier either right
so I mean there's this paper the words
are stupidity
so if you say something that you didn't
say about win-win for the assumption
about win-win for the Assumption okay
that's again
the hardware assumption yeah
um good if we could read proteins easily
sequence proteins
my feeling is this was solutionized the
world but how exactly good so I don't
really know I asked a friend of mine but
I just asked him this morning uh
seriously I can find his answers let's
see if I remember it what he's also a
good journalist no he's a PhD biology
student at Columbia but his like
everyday work is related to mass spec so
the first thing he said I said what
would happen hypothetically if
it was easy to read protein and
duplicate proteins and he's like well
first of all my life would be in the lab
would be much much easier running lab
experiments I don't have to throw away
the protein and start over from DNA okay
but this maybe PhD students should have
a hard life
um
I tried to remember what he said he said
you could see oh good here's something
he said so given let's say you had a
virus and that you don't know anything
about you know you were infected from
this protein but you don't know how if
you could sequence and read it you could
learn a lot about the virus the the
protome I think it's called as uh like
genome there's protome
foreign
we could find out
if you have the protein but not the DNA
that generated it you have a non-pure
impure Proline protein with lots of
other stuff I mean it's always impure
usually but it's always impure I just
remembered something I forgot to say one
second let me think it just um
um yes I remembered something the mass
spec related to the beginning of my talk
not only do they need it to be pure and
a lot they also the way they read it
they have a code book with a list of
known proteins and they somehow need to
look it up they don't know how to read
the Protein that's random that they
don't know anything about it's really
really hard to read protein so this will
help uh you learn all of this but
somehow I feel like
you know breaking the central dogma of
biochemistry
sounds better than side Channel attack
no
I don't know in any case having many
many assumptions is good right the
challenges I'll put back the what the
critics say in the first slide yeah we
can continue this faster yeah
good behavior you have 93 minutes for
lunch
foreign